I think that there's a tiny bit of
sarcasm that I bring to the character at
times yeah um that is very dim if I'd um
but I also wanted to bring empowerment
to her character hmm
girl Smurfs mean business the cast of
Smurfs The Lost village is star-studded
but before going blue they all thought
they blew it and Hollywood at one time
or another hmm
for you it was this movie right I mean
I've been fired from jobs before what
don't blemish I should sully the good
name that matters but you can't get too
comfortable in this industry because you
never know when something might go away
or be taken away I feel like I went
through a lot of stuff growing up and I
went through some challenges and some
obstacles and I felt like get a period
of time I probably wasn't gonna work
again but as I overcame those struggles
it actually gave me more of a I found my
purpose there met all what about you
guys I kind of look at every single time
I blew it as a learning experience so
for me to probably my mouth you know I
tell I call it how I see it I really
don't care what people think
that's what we love about you dawn yeah
that's what I love about myself and most
of it was you know working in a male
dominant industry you know where people
just you know might feel a little
intimidated that you're your own person
I was just showing my true colors and
people didn't like it I like the moments
that I blew it was uh well the first job
in Hollywood that I was offered was this
role in spider-man and two weeks later
my roommate came home and said that her
friend audition
the role that they gave me and the head
of the studio didn't think I was right
for the part because I didn't look like
the character in the comic book so they
took it away the rule wound up coming
back my way because they didn't find
anyone else mmm that's right which is
how they put it I which didn't make me
feel great but but that was that was a
tough pill to swallow up until you're
actually rolling camera and then you're
sitting in a theater watching yourself
up on screen you just don't know
[Music]
you